this week on q a a look at a documentary
on subprime mortgages and their impact
on minorities in baltimore
american casino is co-produced by
husband and wife team andrew and leslie
coburn
[Music]
leslie coburn
when did you first think about doing the
american casino documentary
well um january of 2008
uh andrew and i
decided to do the film
um we'd wanted to do something together
a feature documentary project and we're
watching the market very closely after
what happened in 2007 you had a mini
crash in august and then you had a
couple of barristers hedge funds
just disappeared
um
and also by that time you had on the
courthouse steps in any city around here
around washington you had
these auction you know houses being
auctioned once every three minutes
basically so we could see at that point
that the one important first of all both
of us thought that it could be as
important as 1929.
um
i'd just been reading john kenneth
galbraith's book on 29
and andrew's father covered the crash of
1929 so
we could see these the rumblings and
thought we better jump on this now and
that to with a documentary like this we
could actually tie together what was
happening in a place like baltimore with
wall street
after you got the idea what did you do
next
well we um
we started talking to people we um
we started i mean once you know
what we do as as journalists is we've
you know we trained to
master you know get in touch with the
subject very quickly we started to look
around to see who was doing interesting
interesting reporting about this and we
came across uh
mark pittman at bloomberg who had been
writing about this before really anyone
else um had already spotted what was
happening
and we also started going to baltimore
to um
you know to see what was happening on
the ground
and
serendipitously we you know started to
meet people who ended up in our film i'm
very
we wanted to meet uh people who
were the
not sort of the feckless borrowers of
you know wolf the wall street journal
editorial page like like to describe
them you know the subprime victims as
but you know to see meet the ordinary
mainstream borrower who was getting into
trouble so we went to things like
foreclosure workshops in
[Music]
in baltimore people trying to wrestling
with you know what how to get out of
this situation um
and we met there was one of those we met
patricia mcnair who's a johns hopkins
therapist who's in the film
so we really um
you know we started to sort of graft
ourselves into the subject both in wall
street
and in
baltimore and in a way even at that
stage which is january
08
what really i remember the memory i have
of that period was how
inside how terrified people were on wall
street people were talking in very
apocalyptic terms about uh
i remember a trader at a bank of one of
the
someone who traded in derivatives of one
of the big banks told me he said i'm
sitting here looking at my six screens
and it feels like armageddon
oh my god but this hadn't yet got onto
the front pages of the papers that we
were really going over a clip here
where do you find money for something
like this
investors
fortunately documentaries like this
aren't that expensive to make
you know i've been making documentaries
for making films for 30 years now so
i know how to make something without
spending way too much money it's really
about
editing as much as possible in the
camera really
so we had the camera people who worked
on it were people who we'd worked with
for many years the editor was someone
who'd i'd been at cbs with for many
years
we edited at do art which is one of the
great old production houses in new york
and so there are ways to do things
without
uh spending huge amounts of money and
you go to private investors there are a
number of area places to go to find
people who will put in
relatively small amounts of money but
this we're not talking about a
multi-million dollar project here
you know this is less than a million
dollars who did you want to see it
wanted
several classes of people we wanted
people to see it who were themselves
themselves experiencing you know that
this sort of nightmare of foreclosure we
wanted to show that
whoever calls this it wasn't people
who'd gotten themselves well necessarily
people who'd gotten themselves you know
into debt because there was a there's a
strain of thought in this country
in this in this crisis
that somehow it's the victim's fault you
know people took out loans they couldn't
afford um and so they got what was
coming to them um
we wanted to show people who are in that
situation that there were you know lots
of people like them
and maybe they'd been unwise but they
hadn't been sort of wicked in taking out
this kind of
getting into this kind of trouble and
it's you know something faced by a lot
of people who are in other ways
completely responsible and
i guess beyond that we wanted everyone
to see it because we this is a huge this
is a mega event
i mean mark pittman who's in the film he
called it at one point he said to us and
he said this is a hundred year storm
so we want people to people everyone
wants to know what happened you know how
come suddenly there we were rolling
merrily along price of houses going up
you know economy looking good fi
unemployment you know under five percent
and suddenly boom we're over a cliff and
you know unemployment is 10 or north of
that what happened so we want to show
people that there's a lot of
shots in the opening of
you know the
boards in new york and all that stuff
but we're not going to show that i'm
going to go where i suspected when i saw
it was the political point for you both
and we combined two things let's watch
that it's a couple minutes and we'll
come back you can explain why you chose
this
depression this is a mental recession
you know we've never been more dominant
we've never had more natural advantages
than we had today
we've sort of become a nation of wine
to understand why this is like a
gambling casino you have to understand
what's at stake here
on a december evening december fifteenth
two thousand around seven o'clock
phil graham republican senator of texas
and chair of the senate finance
committee
walked to the floor of the senate and
introduced a
262-page bill
as a writer to the 11 000 page
appropriation bill
which excluded from regulation
the financial instruments that are
probably most at the heart of the
present meltdown
[Music]
not only excluded them from all federal
regulation but he excluded them from
state regulation as well
which is important because these
instruments could be viewed to be
gambling instruments where you're
betting on whether people will or will
not pay off their loans
and he announced the time that this
measure
would be a boon to the american economy
and be a boon to wall street because
they would be freed of any supervision
in this regard
too many
american
families too many minorities
do not own a home
there is a
homeownership gap
in america
the difference between
uh anglo-america and african-american
hispanic
homeownership is too big
we've got to focus the attention on this
nation to address this
and it starts with setting a goal and so
by the year 2010
we must increase minority homeowners
by at least five and a half million
was that right is this where you thought
the politics of all this started
phil graham george bush
well we chose um
phil graham because you know there are a
lot of things that happened you can you
can choose a lot of dates but the
legislation uh in december of 2000 was
the really big one because it said
basically that you couldn't outlaw
derivatives i mean you couldn't it it
made it uh if you if you read it it's
very clear that it's that it protects
these derivatives credit default swaps
etc and it allowed them to just balloon
beyond control and graham was was very
was absolutely instrumental in that and
remember michael greenberger whose voice
you hear and who's talking about it uh
who's now you know he's a lawyer and
professor at the university of maryland
law school
uh greenberger was a regulator
so
he was on the commodity futures trading
commission so in 19 early as 1998 he was
he would have liked to outlaw these
kinds of derivatives that have gotten us
into so much trouble um but he himself
said that that point into in december of
2000 was the absolute critical moment
and phil graham is the person who pushed
that through
where did you happen to get this video
oh for phil gramm yes what is he doing
now he's
what is he doing now he's uh well he
apparently he's vice chairman he's gone
to he's enjoying his reward as vice
chairman of the union bank of
switzerland um
he's still very powerful in texas
politics i believe and uh but if you go
back to that time period in the year
2000 september he didn't do this in a
vacuum that was attached to an
appropriations bill did that go through
at conference had it ever been discussed
in the house of representatives you know
well it had been discussed in fact and
had failed they tried to introduce that
commodity futures
money futures modernization act as a
separate bill and it hadn't gone through
it had failed so what they then did what
graham did with uh
sure plenty of willing assistance was to
tack it on to an appropriations bill
this is december 15 2000
um you know everyone's wanting to go
home for christmas bill clinton is about
to leave office uh so clinton signed it
and there was it's 262 pages and tacked
onto an 11 000 page bill so how many
people do you think
actually read it i mean graham if you
look at the congressional record
there's a speech by graham introducing
the bill
and i went to your
excellent organization to c-span to get
the tape and your researchers
dug and delved and tried to find the
tape and then came back and said well
there is no tape because he didn't
actually give that speech it was
inserted in the record afterwards
so
this momentous piece of legislation
wasn't even
spoken in the uh in the heart in the uh
in the senate let alone
stood for the record this is the first
time i knew you came to our organization
i had no idea so i mean people do it all
the time but i just want everybody to
know that's not why you're here uh go
back to the george bush clip my memory
serves me that was at george washington
university
well actually um
he made that exact same speech
again and again and again in
in 2002 which was very interesting
because um he was i mean you could look
at it one way saying that he was
um
completely um
uh you know very anxious for for
for
minorities to have
decent housing or you could say i wonder
what forces were at play in 2002 to
encourage him to do this i think it was
coming from a lot of directions
if you look at it from wall street in
2002 that was a critical time in the
life of cdos collateralized debt
obligations because it was just about
that time that the smart people on wall
street decided
that instead of being so diversified in
these securities why not just load them
up with subprime loans
so it was a very dangerous moment they
started pouring subprime loans into
these
products
and at such large numbers
that um that it made them much more
vulnerable to exploding what were the
democrats doing along this way about the
idea of subprime mortgages
not enough i mean there was no one
i mean it's fair to say that no one
really at that time was you know raising
alarms i mean they were
i think sheila bear now you know the
chairman of the fdic um
running the fdic she was one of the
early people to go to
inside to go to greenspan at the fed and
say look this is looking rather
dangerous uh you should you know there's
another now dead mr gramlick who was a
governor of the fed he was raising
concerns
certainly by 2004 but
apart from some people on wall street
who started to bet against subprime
loans in 2005 i don't you know you could
say that
unfortunately no one really
raised the alarm when it might have made
a big difference in this next clip uh
mark pittman is a part of it and i know
he's died since and i'll ask you about
that
in a moment but and also david uh is it
addisoni
mortgage broker before we show this
where did you find the mortgage broker
david assani was not a mortgage broker
um david adessani worked on wall street
for a number of firms and he asked us in
fact not to mention the various firms
where he worked but they they would all
be extremely familiar to you and
you know as he describes in the film
some of them no longer existed by the
time we went to see him
what he was doing was he was marketing
these selling these
you know
mortgage
mortgages bundled into into bonds and he
was selling these securities to other
banks around wall street here's this
clip
i worked for four companies on wall
street
three of them don't exist anymore
i don't think anything's really
permanent in life i mean sure my
grandfather worked at the same company
for you know 20 some odd years in the
stillness of pittsburgh maybe 30 years i
don't know but he worked the same
company's whole life nothing's permanent
anymore
the stock market goes south bank's going
out of business
it's just the way
people in america live
i don't think anything i've done
propelled or inhibited i don't think no
i don't feel any any responsibility for
for this mess at all
it really started getting heated in
2004
2005.
mortgage rates kept dropping
for prime mortgages you know the ones
that most people get
and that made the others much more
valuable because they
offered much more yield
when you have that much cash flow that's
extra
you can siphon off a whole lot more fees
and that then that is you know it's all
about money
why did you go to mark pittman
because mark pittman
it was you know when you're trying to
explain this stuff in a film you really
you want to take it slowly and mark was
very very good at explaining how these
things worked and
therefore i wanted to start with him
because he's he talks about when when
the whole subprime market started
heating up and he makes this very
important point you know there are a lot
of people who don't even know what
subprime means so you you really had to
explain that that you get more yield you
get more money out of it the guys on
wall street make more money out of
subprime loans and that was a key thing
and also he introduced the ideas of the
fees which
indeed were extremely important it's
everything on wall street is fee based
certainly with this whole crisis
um the things that people were packaging
they wanted to do more and more and more
because the yields were so good and the
fees were so good
so um mark is a you know one of the best
uh unfortunately he
at age of 52 he had a heart attack
recently
uh but marcus was one of the great
financial reporters of our time as
economist joe stiglitz said recently and
so um and i also felt and andrew did as
well that mark was from kansas city he
has um a real presence he's a real
all-american guy and he really is a
populist in that he
um you know he loves wall street he
loved covering wall street but he really
wanted the rules to be fair was it a
surprise that he died of a heart attack
or did you know he was not well
no no i mean maybe people's family knew
but no it was a terrible shock that he
um
you know when we suddenly heard that
he'd gone i mean it was he'd been
he'd been so much
part of our lives i mean we got to know
him so well during
making the film and even after the film
appeared um he was very supportive and
you know was always always ready to
explain you know to come and do a q a to
explain to people because he really
wanted
ordinary people not well you know not
necessarily wall street professionals to
understand this that this you know this
huge these huge events which
are superficially very complicated that
he wanted to understand them so people
would know what had happened
by the way uh i saw it in the theater in
washington can you see it around the
country now or can you buy the dvd
right now it's been in a theatrical run
for two and a half months and so it's
over now it's just opened in europe at
the film festival in amsterdam so here
you can buy it on dvd you can buy it on
our website which is
americancasinothemovie.com
americancasinothemovie.com and it costs
so much
for home viewing it costs 24.95 shipping
included
and what did what does it determine uh
for either one of you what
makes this a success
various there's various ways one of them
the
one we like best is when people see the
film and come out and say now i
understand now i get it what's happened
i understand i didn't understand how why
the
you know the economy suddenly spun out
of control what happened on wall street
it all seemed so complicated now i've
seen your film and i understand
that's
i think
certainly my favorite yardstick
well also when this film first opened it
was at the tribeca film festival in new
york in the spring
we had three screenings and
they were packed with wall street people
the wall street people it was very
interesting because after
at the end of each screening it turned
into a real town meeting these guys
stood up and they started talking to
each other and it gave them the first
opportunity
to really i mean they were yelling each
other the ratings guys were yelling at
the brokers and it was quite lively and
it was exciting to see
wall street react to this and it was the
first time a lot of those people
understood what effect they had on
people's lives i want to come back to
that but here's another clip because
when you talk about ratings people this
will help
fill in the blanks
you almost have to follow the money here
right
because
they're taking their fee from the
investment banks in fact that rating
agencies wouldn't even run
their own models
meaning that when they rated a deal
they would take
their rating agency model give it to the
investment bank
the investment bank would run the entire
model for them
and then give them the results
and then the results would go to a
rating agency analyst and that analyst
would take it to committee and that they
would eventually
agree on the rating but they didn't run
their own models
how do you know this uh because i worked
at an investment bank and was running
the models for them
[Music]
i was requested by the head of the cdo
group to put some ratings on some bonds
that had come in as part of a particular
cdo
but we didn't have any information we'd
never seen the tape we hadn't read the
legals
and so we wrote back and said our
criteria requires that we have the tape
and that we have the legals to make sure
it meets our criteria
and they wrote back and said we can't
get any of that
you just guess
and put a rating on it
and uh that was clearly a violation of
our ethics so i just told him i wouldn't
do it
[Music]
what's the importance of this
well the the ratings agencies uh frank
rader was a senior executive at standard
poor's he was in charge of all
residential mortgage-backed securities
the rating thereof
they're like they were absolutely
crucial to the whole
system and to the disaster because
they were the ones who said
you know this investment was you know it
could be rated triple a meaning it's
super safe it's never going to go broke
or double a or double b
and what they did was as it emerges um
from what you know frank is saying and
uh from what uh the bank of the
anonymous bankers say
what their essential function in this
whole what's gone on was to take things
that were actually you know well
subprime mortgages which were inherently
not so credit worthy
and basically through the magic of
securitization and everything to um
to say that they were invest you know
triple a which was something we used to
only apply to things like general
electric and the exxon corporation so
they basically took garbage and they
spray painted it with gold paint and
said this is gold
and you know trillions of dollars were
invested on that basis
uh in stuff that was really garbage but
had been made to look like was presented
as gold
and because of that that is why we've
had such a huge disaster because
you know things were basically assigned
false ratings because according to this
anonymous banker at least i mean we know
he is but
he didn't want his name you used
they were basically in bed they they
were being paid by the investment banks
to give these ratings
and in fact the investment banks were
doing the rating you know we're running
the models as he said and then basically
these were rubber stamped by the ratings
agency and then passed on to the public
moody's fitch i believe is that the name
there's the big three there's moody's
standard and poor which the biggest two
and then fitch
go back to that scene where we saw the
investment banker in silhouette can you
tell us where where that what what that
scene was behind him
irrelevant
not giving away who he is i mean is that
your value i won't say i won't say what
it is behind it it's just uh
it's not a it's not a real picture
behind him and he's not no it's real
he's sitting in a real place and it's
there's nothing distorted there he's
simply his voice is distorted and he's
he's dark it's his silhouette how did
you find him
well that took a long time that took um
you know we spent months and months and
months talking to more and more and more
people on wall street and you know how
you do it you meet one person and
finally they say i want to introduce you
to somebody we it was very important to
us to meet the guys who were absolutely
at the heart of the business of making
cdos these collateralized debt
obligations that blew up in everybody's
face
it takes time
and we had many many meetings with
groups of of these people from different
banks this person happened to have been
a bear at bear stearns
he was
very brilliant at what he did
i don't want to say too much more about
him except that
he represents a group and it's not a big
group of people who really understood
these these securitized vehicles
the problem for wall street people with
coming on camera and showing their face
the reason why you don't see them all
the time is they have deferred
compensation rules so that if you went
on camera you could lose literally
millions of dollars in compensation and
also you know you kind of sign away your
life when you take one of these jobs and
you and
you agree to a lot of things that make
it very difficult for you to go public
so that's why you hear so many experts
but you rarely get to hear the bankers
like him talk the way bankers talk to
each other and that was a we couldn't
have made this film without because he's
the heart of the matter really um
in that you know there's a moment i
don't know whether you have it in your
clips but there's a moment later on
where he actually takes you through
how you make a cdo and from a cdo how
you make a cdo squared and at that
moment the audience understands the
incredible scam
of making these things
that were packed with in some cases you
know a million and a half subprime loans
rated triple a and sold off to
as he describes the korean bankers
but the ratings agencies there is this
inherent conflict of interest here the
ratings agencies the big three
you have the government saying everybody
has to
you know they have this kind of quasi
government uh it's the stamp of approval
so they're acting as our regulators and
yet they're paid
by the investment banks
and um
you know the guys in korea or in germany
they're not going to buy anything nor is
the california pension fund going to buy
anything that doesn't have a triple-a
rating well you'd think that that would
be the first thing that would have been
changed
since this whole thing you know frank
rader the ratings executive said
uh if if only these the what he had been
doing if if it had been tightened up
this whole thing wouldn't happen
but right now
um
it's not being they're not being
regulated relationship with the banks is
still the same
uh the only thing you really see is
there are a couple of dozen suits around
the country against the ratings agencies
i know that uh ohio has taken the lead
in that they're
suing them so we'll see what happens go
back to that tribeca film festival in
new york city where you showed this
three times
and there were the discussions that
broke out afterwards were you there in
the audience yeah we were you know we
were it started off as people asking us
questions but as the wall street you
know someone was as he said
the house was basically full of wall
street people um
and pretty soon instead of you know us
having to answer the question someone
else would jump up from another part of
the theater and say wait a minute you
know i was uh you were the ratings
agency you did that well you know it was
your fault not ours and
it turned into this extraordinary debate
this town meeting did anybody in that in
those sessions get mad at you for what
you'd how you portrayed them in the film
no no no no everyone i mean that was
gratifying people no one people didn't
get mad at us they were
in a way they were pleased that you know
that we
we'd laid the whole thing out um it was
almost cathartic for them that here was
a forum you know the
way we were providing a sort of backdrop
on a forum so they could really you know
say have their say and talk about what
had happened how did you two divide up
the responsibilities
well leslie is the filmmaker here she's
the she directed the film i mean i
i did journalism um
and um who wrote the script
oh leslie
well there isn't much of a script in
this film this is uh
it's just people talking you know we
have no narration
so it's just
and and when you see the writing on the
on the cards it's deliberately very dry
it's very straightforward so it isn't a
script that's pulling you through the
film it's the people who are pulling you
through so
although we both share a writing credit
i would say there isn't really a script
at all it's simply
it's laid out so that one person follows
on from the last person and to explain
it how much of the music is original
well andrew found the original music
it's um
we were because we were spending time in
baltimore and we knew you know i knew
that we knew that baltimore you know
very musical city
so suddenly thought well maybe uh you
know maybe people are doing music about
this maybe there's some kind of you know
because we looked we'd had other tracks
you know using
um bruce springsteen singing woody
guthrie and so forth that's also in the
film but i went to baltimore and
asked around and found there's a very uh
sort of local local uh music studio
there and said what does anyone you know
what's the chances of getting any sort
of
current sort of street music about
foreclosure and mortgages and this
nightmare that's happening
and actually 60 got we got 60 tracks
presented to us um which we use three
which are just these kids i mean the
most one that's we play used twice in
the the over the end credits in the film
and then the end credits was a group of
three young people aged 11 to 14 who
were recruited who got together at an
after-school program um
and recorded this very sort of
heartbreaking song called losing my home
at the very very end when they when you
run the billboards yeah the numbers yeah
well why don't we run a little bit of
that and so uh
we can see what you're talking about
it's one of those things baby hard to
explain government policies when insane
i don't understand you work all the time
yeah i work hard but it's just not
enough we gotta hang your name cause
these times
crying
i'm devastated
again those how old were those kids uh
at the time 11 to 14 who wrote the song
um they did they had the producer was a
very talented lady in baltimore called
emotion i mean she helped i think she
helped tidy up the i mean sort of help
them with the lyrics but it was their
idea
and they you know they composed it and
it was based basically on personal
personal experience
those numbers that we were seeing on the
screen were what
they were the numbers
from this last summer of the total
bailout
that's been given to the financial
sector by
us the
well both by the treasury and by the
federal reserve
as you can see the numbers are kind of
enormous um we keep hearing we've heard
a lot about the 700 billion dollar
top
program
and that's often spoken of as the sum
total of what's been given in help to
wall street but as you can see from here
it's a lot more than that in fact the
total
commitment was 12 trillion dollars of
which what 4 trillion has been spent so
far so it's um we you know most people
don't quite realize how much of
our money and you know our you know our
credit as you know
american citizens has been invested in
shoring up this uh wall street how hard
was it to get these figures
we got these figures um
from mark pittman and bob every this the
bloomberg team
mark pittman decided early on that he
wanted to do his own figures he didn't
believe the figures he wanted to check
it out himself
and the two of them did
did it twice they did it in uh
see they did it in january first that
when it was 8 trillion
the government had committed by that
time 8 trillion and by march it was 12
trillion now it's uh obviously higher
make a little bit of a transition here
we'll see one uh fella that we saw
earlier but then we moved to the
baltimore scene and you'll see
the teacher that you got involved in
this one
some people ask you know
what do you think caused all this you
know um i always say
i think it comes down to greed
[Music]
this place was our house man it's where
we call home now we gotta give it up
cause the subprime loans they ain't
chasing they hit for so long since i was
a kid i remember every moment everything
that we did all the functions
[Music]
[Music]
i just think it's immoral for there to
be such a huge boom
around the housing industry
a lot of people made a lot of money
but now all of these people who bought
during that period are losing their
homes
i teach about social justice issues
human rights issues i mean i actually
have a class issues of social justice
and human rights let's take a little
quiz and i've been considering
talking with my students about the
mortgage crisis and what that does
there's a loss of security um
you know this
huge stress
is terrible forty thousand can you bid a
forty i got thirty seven thousand eight
eighty nine do i hear forty thousand
thirty seven thousand eight hundred and
eighty nine dollars and ninety nine
cents on the advance at this time
thirty seven thousand eight hundred
eighty nine dollars and ninety nine
cents once
twice third and final call
let's walk back from the foreclosure
auction there on the steps of what
courthouse steps baltimore
um and we went uh
you know you could any day of the week
at that time in early 2008 you could see
these guys on the steps selling these
houses
a very long list every morning
so what we did was we went to the
auctions and simply drove around
baltimore with our cameras going to
these different addresses and on the
first day we did it one of the first
houses we went to
was the house that belonged to the high
school teacher denzel mitchell the house
that had just been auctioned uh with a
caveat that uh that it could be affected
by bankrupt a bankruptcy filing we went
and he had just come back from filing
for bankruptcy that morning so he was at
his house he was loading up all the
boxes um the house had been completely
dismantled so we went around the house
with him he was in complete shock but
that's how we found denzel and it turns
out of course he was you know incredibly
articulate and a very very interesting
case because we were able eventually to
track his mortgage
all the way into a
um
securitized product at goldman sachs
the amelien wade said the correct name
is she's a reverend
yeah how'd you find her
um we found her just through sort of
word of mouth in baltimore someone said
there was this
minister of the church who was um
who was living in her car
who daddy you know
we were interested particularly because
something i mentioned earlier which is
you know the people say oh well these
people got into trouble because they
took out loans they they couldn't afford
they wanted to buy a bigger and better
house they were you know getting houses
they didn't deserve
armeline was one of the many people who
who've lost their homes who owned our
house free and clear she didn't
she inherited that house from her
parents
um
and then took out a loan on the house to
uh
she wanted to make some improvements
because she wanted to sort of do us
have an assisted living sort of
operation in the house for people in the
church and um
you know was borrowed 28 000
and as she says in the film
she's you know her life is destroyed
she's lost her house she's you know
living in a car and she's hard to
believe that all this happened because
of 28 000 here's a little bit from the
reverend wade right now i live my life
in pain and some days i'm depressed
because i miss my home
i'm homeless and
it's just hard it's a struggle it's
devastating
it's upsetting
it's unbelievable but it's real
i don't have a home anymore
and i'll never forget this as long as i
live
this is a house that i grew up in most
of my life
i came here in 1961 with my mother and
my father
i've been here a lifetime
and i went to school here i went to
junior high school went to high school
went to college
and we used to have a church next door
and the neighborhood was just home this
was just home
i wanted to do a um assistant living
here i wanted to help people
and the property wasn't in the proper
condition that it needed to be so i was
advised to take the equity out of the
property some of the equity and do a
loan
start my project that way the loan was
for 28 thousand dollars it's really sad
that all of this was lost over 28
thousand dollars the monthly payments
was close to like 300 a month but i was
on a fixed income and it was just it
just got to be too much
wells fargo was the mortgage servicer
and that too serviced my loan and who i
got the loan through i really at that
particular time didn't know all the ins
and out of a mortgage loan i
just took it by faith that i was going
to be okay
settlement was really fast
you just don't know you know you're
trusting your mortgage broker you're
trusting the settlement people you're
trusting the bank and what else can you
do you really don't have a clue you're
just happy to have someone say yes we
will finance you
yes you are approved yes you can go to
settlement
what would happen today from what you
know if she went in for a loan like she
got before
if she was looking for a loan means
anything changed
she said she doesn't she trusted all
these people she would not get a loan at
this point
you know lone
it's it's much much much tougher to get
a loan these days
so no i mean i she shouldn't have been
given a loan at that point
and uh and
she knows that at now
what happened to her church
i mean it's um
the church is gone i mean she's you know
she's not functioning as a minister now
um she's
basically surviving um i mean just the
question on the loan that alone was for
seven and a half percent i mean that's
it was already and it was actually
had the possibility of rising to just i
think third almost 13 13 um with a
possible rise every six months how much
responsibility does the individual have
in this to read i know that there's
stacks and stacks of paper but uh how
much of it is our responsibility
well that's we explored that at some
length in the film and uh we have um
you know you meet in the film you meet
robert strop for example who's a
community lawyer and ann norton who's
another community lawyer in baltimore
and both of them they're very smart
lawyers say that believe me
smart lawyers don't understand all the
jargon in these loans and the loans were
all tied to all kinds of fancy numbers
and uh
libor rates and stuff that was very
individually tailored not all these
loans were alike so even if you'd read
one of them all the way through you
wouldn't necessarily know what the next
one was going to be like and frankly no
one reads their loan documents i haven't
actually run into a human being who has
read every single document before they
sign and robert stratt points out
that
in the film he points out that these the
uh
that it got so laxed that people as he
said people were uh
signing being signed up for mortgages
you know on the hood of their car
um it was uh they it would be done late
in the afternoon when people had to pick
up their kids from daycare
and that they would be penalized if they
monetarily if they didn't pick them up
on time so you're going to have to pay a
fee so you have a half an hour you sign
the documents uh and what what happened
often in baltimore and elsewhere
which we found out from the community
groups like st ambrose that helps people
who are in terrible trouble
because of foreclosure that they would
get to the signing and the numbers were
different
this happened to denzel mitchell they
would get to the signing they'd be told
one thing
so they really believed that they could
afford these payments and they'd get to
the signing and it wouldn't be the same
number because uh various things
obligations have been left out so there
was a real sleight of hand going on
it's interesting that in the in the next
clip we're going to see the mayor of
baltimore who has since been convicted
of one count
and i'd it's it's she hasn't been
sentenced yet but it was she was charged
with a lot of of uh accounts that were
dropped or she was acquitted but she was
found guilty since then and her name is
dixon sheila dixon let's watch this and
i'll ask you about that and and the
other people we see
you have people that are homeless
looking for a place to live so an
unoccupied house becomes a house that
gets broken into they know other
homeless people that need a place to
stay they take over the house and they
start renting rooms so they start their
own business on a house that somebody's
left
we're going to check the reddest
property baltimore was real prime for
investors
investors come in they see an
opportunity to grab a property they'll
start doing some rehab and try to sell
it to somebody the first time home buyer
they can take advantage of some of the
programs out there for first time home
buyers but let's just be clear investors
are in business to make money they want
to return on their investment do they
really care whether or not the person
can hold on to the home for the long
haul probably not because once the
property is sold they're gone
i think the record reflects that this is
a part of a foreclosure as well
as part of the pain
part of the pain in the city
when you have to put additional revenue
and support in the neighborhood by
boarding up homes by other people's
properties depreciating as a result of
the vacant properties i mean it takes
away
revenue that you can use to
restabilize the area
so it's costing us with additional
police fire
resources coming out of housing and
community development and all those
other support services that help to
keep a community thriving and growing
had she been indicted when you
interviewed her no
no
and um
do you know what exactly what happened
to her when and when she was convicted
of one count and she has not been
sentenced she's not been sentenced um so
you know whether
she'll have to step down as mayor or not
as at this time isn't clear i mean
there's plenty of people who
you know baltimore's very political city
plenty of people who who'd like the job
um
but you know i got to say what she was
you know what she's whether or not she
was convicted or anything or whatever
she did any mayor in america could have
said and would have said i certainly
should say what she said i mean that
this crisis
has
you know has had this incredible sort of
municipal effect on cities um
because you have suddenly the tax base
shrinks all these houses are empty
you've got a huge problem with abandoned
property which they're trying like in
baltimore and a lot of other cities
they're uh trying to force the uh force
the the banks the people who've you know
foreclosed taken the property back to at
least maintain them you know to cut the
grass and stop them turning into sort of
into into ruins
um
and um you know it cost them
um you know huge amounts costing city a
huge amount to sort of pull you know to
look after these houses you saw the crew
earlier who are going around boarding
them up um
trying to deal with squatters who move
in and do sort of irresponsible things
like leaving the oven on um
you know danger of burning down the
block so this
this you know what what we're trying to
what we're explaining in that segment is
this isn't just things that happen
something that happens to an individual
an individual homeowner
what it does
what it's done is impact whole cities i
mean
among other something else i mean when a
house goes into foreclosure when that
house that was boarded up
when that went into foreclosure the hut
the bank takes it back and then the bank
may later auction it off at 50 cents on
the dollar or whatever certainly just to
get rid of it that crashes the price of
every other house in the in the
neighborhood and so you get you know
everyone else's house values are going
down so more and more people are finding
that
they are paying you know they're they're
paying more for their mortgage is now
much greater than the value of their
house so they made for default and it's
you know as an escalating thing but it's
had a huge effect on american cities i
want to remind uh anybody watching they
want to watch the whole documentary it's
american casino movie
is your website and you can buy it for
24.95
and it's been in the theaters for the
last couple weeks does it bother you
when you see us chop up your documentary
because you're setting a mood
as you you watch it and by the way how
long is it
it's 89 minutes so it's it's the a
regular feature length and i'm i'm i
don't mind it it's actually fascinating
to see what you've chosen you've chosen
different things from from other people
in terms of the clips there's a lot of
things we could have chosen as you know
and this is there's a lot missing from
this yeah well you when you make a film
you're building a mood throughout you're
going through and there's certain
rhythms but um but there are also
sections of it that are self-contained i
know numbers are sensitive can you give
us a range of what this kind of thing
cost to do
uh
you know i i'm not sure what other
people would
spend on something like this
uh i i suspect that we spend less simply
because
when when you've been making films for a
long time what you do is you waste
less material um there's there's
something called a ratio which you might
it might be 50 to 1 or 20 to one in
terms of the hours that you shoot and
the hours that you actually use
and uh for us it's it's quite low is it
can i get arranged like
documentaries has cost something between
a half a million and a million
oh i think that some people
you know it can go from a half it can go
from less than a half a million it could
go from a quarter of a million to
2.5 or 3 million some people can spend
quite a lot if you have a big staff if
you have a lot of people
if you're running around the world
if you're shooting a lot
you can really
how much shooting days did you have
oh i can't remember exactly how many
days but um uh
let's see it's probably
maybe 30
30 shooting there's only one day i think
it's just of all the days we shot
i think it was only one day where we
didn't use something from the day i mean
every everything practically everything
got used
everything we shot got used but every
day we got something from every day in
the edit room people can spend
months if not years in the edit room on
documentaries or regular features and
and we
were moving along at a very at the sort
of pace that we're that we have to move
if we're working with front line or 60
minutes or any of these places where you
really you have a deadline and when was
the last day
that you finished your work
well we
we added a couple of things we finished
in february and then in march we
one of the people who we focused on in
baltimore
uh who was in the process of foreclosure
they lost their home so we added it to
the film that they had lost the home
and then um
in august we at the very sorry end of
july we added uh some figures right at
the end to make sure that all the
figures were correct before we close
down we've got a couple minutes to go i
like to go back and get video from when
we first met and that was on book notes
in september of 1991.
i don't think i've seen you since then
andrew was here for another show let's
watch this is where story a little bit
of where you two met
we met in uh in london
years ago
uh we met at a at a
club called zanzibar actually in london
what were you doing
i was um at the time i was finishing
graduate school over there at soaz which
is the school of oriental and african
studies i was also had just started
working at nbc news
where's home originally san francisco
and what is your relationship
well
we're married and uh we work together we
make films together for pbs frontline
and we write books together so it's a
very close relationship what other books
have you written
uh this is our first together but uh i
wrote a book called out of control which
was about um
the reagan administration activities in
central america it was about covert
operations down there and wrote a book
called the threat which was about the
soviet military where were you from
originally i was from ireland i grew up
in ireland uh my father's scottish but
uh where in ireland uh county cork east
cork and what was life like growing up
there and when did you leave there
uh
life was interesting it was like uh
actually we didn't have a the early
years we didn't have a car
or a telephone or a fridge so i grew up
we you know went everywhere by horse uh
i grew up in a sort of 19th century way
and there was no difference between the
way we were living and someone 100 years
before um communicated by telegrams
perfectly i can tell people who
under the age of 110 that it's a
perfectly viable way to live um
i left there i guess when i was
17
and went to work in london
how many books and documentaries and
front lines have you done since 1991
oh god um well there's been let's see
one
two
three
three four books
front lines has been a couple
many 60 minutes because many many my my
memory
when your dog your daughters are like
about 10 and 7 when you were here before
what's the story now i know one of them
is quite prominent out there in the
world
yes one of them is uh is an actress
she's uh
people would have seen her on house
probably her name is olivia wilde she
plays 13 on house and she also does
movies and
our other daughter
is a lawyer and an artist chloe coburn
and is now doing
uh racial justice issues litigation at
the aclu in new york and we always ask
you about your brothers patrick is where
now
well patrick is uh currently is at home
in uh in canterbury england but he's
deciding whether he's been
deciding whether to whether to return to
kabul or baghdad um that's where he
spends
and alexander alexander is living in
northern california he's got his
web
newsletter counterpunch.org
counterpunch.org and
engaged in never more interesting
architectural projects on his house as a
last clip uh
you you have a little rap song and
secretary hank paulson former treasury
secretary in a hearing situation uh it's
this is only a minute or so let's run
this and then we'll wrap it up
[Music]
this morning we meet we're hearing on
the turmoil of u.s credit markets recent
actions regarding
government-sponsored entities investment
banks and other financial institutions
[Music]
this is not just a cosmetic issue and a
feel-good issue
[Music]
the taxpayer already is going to suffer
the consequences if things don't work
the way they should work welcome to the
great depression
[Music]
[Applause]
the video you must have gone in there
with that idea because you weren't in
the normal position where you shot all
that
well actually it's um it's uh
no it didn't work that way it was shot
before the idea happened um
that music
you might want to say how we ended up
with that music that music we heard
about that that's a herbie hancock track
um
actually written the first of uh i think
he produced in 1982 when there was
actually a bad recession and where i
heard about we heard about it was from
uh former traders from bear stearns who
said they were playing that track in the
bear stearns trading room as things were
going sad um everybody's broke it was
like a
modern
song so that's uh it's a very eloquent
actually if you listen to all the words
it's a very good song about financial
recession in 60 seconds
both of you give you 30 seconds each
what did you learn the mo what was the
most important thing you learned from
this experience
oh
you better go first
so so unfair
well the most important thing to learn
is when they you know what i thought i
thought was when they tell you that
things are too complicated for you to
understand all this financial stuff it's
not true they're just trying to blind
you it's you know it's very simple this
was loan sharking or they you know they
guilt-aged you know
lousy products it's not our fault
i think what i learned is having spent
so much of my life now covering stories
overseas
wars you know
uh sort of post-apocalyptic scenes in
somalia or afghanistan that
what amazed me was how much damage could
be done right here at home
um through this terrible collapse it was
it was really an eye-opener for me to
see hall the destruction
in whole neighborhoods and how just how
bad it can get
leslie coburn and andrew coburn writers
and producers of american casino and
again the website is
americancasinothemovie.com
thank you for joining us and i will run
these credits again so we can see some
of those numbers
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
strong but i can see her breaking down
cause when you get something new they
come around raising mortgage and causing
stress she needs some breath to get the
best for me and her memories of how
beautiful we used to be up in the house
[Music]
without a dime yeah i work hard but it's
just not enough
[Music]
if you missed the entire speech by
chairman bernanke today in atlanta we'll
replay it tonight at 10 15 eastern here
on